if you've been thinking about buying a
new iPad you need to stop wait and
reconsider because you're probably
getting tempted by the latest 10.2 inch
iPad 9 for only 300 bucks on Amazon
which by the way is a killer deal
however stop and wait because this month
we are getting the brand new iPad 10 and
this is gonna be the biggest budget iPad
Revolution that we've ever seen it's
gonna have the biggest changes it's
going to be modernized with some crazy
new features so in this video I'm going
to explain why you should not be buying
this killer iPad 9 deal now I know I've
been telling you guys for the last few
months that the budget iPad for 329
dollars is a great price it's a killer
deal you get the best bang for the buck
but the crazy thing is that it's about
to get even better so good that I might
actually buy one myself now a couple
months back in August everybody was
expecting this new iPad to come at
Apple's September a seventh event but
that did not happen and now we have a
more Clear Vision of when this is
actually going to launch now the weird
thing is that in early August on August
3rd Apple did actually announce that
they're delaying iPad OS 16 until
October which was kind of weird and Mark
Grumman actually put out a story saying
that it's gonna release alongside Mac OS
Ventura which is pretty interesting
which that still has not been released
just yet we still have all the betas now
Joe resignal from Mac Rumors went ahead
and said that it's pretty easy to
imagine an Apple event in October with
the iPad Pro with the M2 Chip the
tension iPad with the iPad OS 16 release
date and I think that makes a lot of
sense originally he did think there was
an option that it could launch at the
September event because if you look back
into the past the last three budget
iPads were released in September but it
looks like apple decided to to wait for
some weird reason and of course we
didn't get it in September so now we are
waiting until October now we did get
some exclusive leaks way back in June
concerning the iPad and it said that it
was going to pack the A14 chip which
actually makes a lot of sense 5G and
finally USBC connectivity that itself is
a really huge deal and the reason for
that is because if you go and buy the
iPad 9 on Amazon right now you're stuck
with a lightning port for the remainder
of how long you're going to own this
device no matter what happens and guess
what Mark German just posted in his
newsletter his power on newsletter just
this past weekend iPhone 15 USBC Port is
essentially a lock so he's basically
saying 100 confirmed from our German
USBC port on next year's iPhone lineup
that is a very big deal not only that he
said that the airpods and Mac
accessories are likely to switch to USBC
by 2024 and that's why it makes so much
sense for this year's budget iPad to
finally get the USBC upgrade because
they've got to transition everything
over to USBC not only that but back in
June Ross young who was the most
reliable analyst in terms of Apple
display leaks he said that we're going
to be getting a 10.5 inch display
instead of the current 10.2 so that's
awesome we get a little bit more screen
real estate and that's going to help it
stand out from all the current budget
iPads which they've been 10.2 inches for
quite a few years I think it's probably
three years now in a row we've had the
10.2 inch size so surprisingly it's only
going to be 0.4 inches off from the iPad
Air which is also a big deal that I've
got to talk about here in just a minute
now my take on that back in June was
that USBC means that we are getting a
full redesign with flat sides because
you wouldn't want a USBC port on a
rounded chamfered Edge like the current
iPads have because it reduces the
durability and then Greg from Greg's
Gadget said also if they switch to USBC
they need to switch the second gen apple
pencil which charges on a flat side so
that's another reason to have the flat
sided redesign which I think is going to
be the perfect time for anybody to buy
and upgrade to a new iPad because that
design is fresh modern and it's sticking
around for a few years now in August we
then got some new leaked CAD files from
my smart price showing exactly that they
showed off the flat sides all the way
around they showed off a new camera bump
which actually looks like the iPhone
10s's camera bump and speaker grilles on
both the bottom and the top and then
here of course you can see that usb-c
Port you see the flat sides and and the
interesting thing that apple is
apparently doing is keeping around that
old front display look as you can see
with the home button still remaining
which is a pretty weird Choice which
they haven't done with all the other
iPads that they transitioned over and I
think the reason for that is because it
might dominate in terms of sales and
kind of cannibalize the iPad Air because
it'll look so similar to the iPad Air
you might not even notice the difference
so that is why Apple might want to keep
the home button around on the cheapest
model and here you can see some really
good renders from renders by shylesh
showing off that iPhone 10s style camera
bump as well as the front display with
home button right there it still looks
pretty nice and Sleek however at the end
of August we did get quite a sketchy
rumor saying that those renders were
actually wrong and that the iPad is
going to have a touch ID power button
just like those other iPads and a a
landscape FaceTime camera which
personally I think this report is wrong
and I think I'm willing to bet that this
is the design that we're gonna get home
button on the front and then going back
to my take from June I think it's gonna
be priced at 399 dollars because Apple's
gonna take advantage of the redesign and
up the price just like they've done with
every single iPad that received the new
modern redesign they've raised the price
so 3.99 makes the most sense and now let
me finish off with why I think this is
going to be the best time ever to buy a
budget iPad first of all that new flat
sided redesign is not going to change
for years it's going to make it feel
fresh for longer and now hopefully with
those quad speaker grilles we're finally
going to have stereo speakers which was
one of the biggest problems with the
budget iPad you'd be holding it in
landscape and you only have sound coming
from one side it's just a terrible
experience compared to all of Apple's
other products their MacBooks have the
best speakers ever their new iPhone 14s
now have the best speakers in any
smartphone but their budget iPad just
terrible terrible speakers on top of
that we're going to be getting the A14
ship which is definitely more than
enough for anything you want to do on
your iPad it's very powerful and of
course the new USB type-c port is going
to be the biggest deal because next year
we're getting USBC on all of the iPhones
and if you decide to take a really good
deal and buy the current iPad 9 with
lightning right now when you eventually
upgrade to a USBC iPhone you're still
going to be stuck with lightning on this
iPad and you're going to be keeping just
that one lightning cable around whereas
if you waited till later this month for
the new iPad 10 you would have had USBC
I think it's a very wise choice to wait
for that so with that said let me know
your thoughts on the new iPad 10 design
do you think it's going to come with the
home button on the front or do you think
it's going to be modernized like the
other iPads let me know your thoughts
down below definitely click the button
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]